what's up guys it's Tucker the intern  today I'm gonna make my co-workers guess  what's inside this box but here's the  thing it's me it's your boy  I hate surprises it feels really hairy I  really hope it's not Tucker but it just  might be because of how bulbous and huge  this head is here's the Box  oh  something's like very sad in here  no  okay it if I had to like describe the  sadness it's someone whose older sibling  like never let them play video games and  they've just kind of like carried that  with them the rest of their life does  that make any sense  ooh it's Harry wait it's it's also wet  I think it's pretty good  you're fooled  and it knows me